[Musique]
3 3 4 1 3 4
[des rires]
J'ai à la fois les meilleurs moments et
des pires moments en même temps Oh mon Dieu
la mienne, qu'est-ce que ça a à voir avec elle et moi
Bien sûr parce qu'au sein de la fiction
nos personnages étaient ensemble et dans
la réalité, nous étions aussi ensemble
Alors, quand nous faisons le
série et nous étions ensemble et notre
les personnages étaient ensemble et nous nous aimions
et ainsi de suite, c'était merveilleux et puis quand
nous n'étions plus ensemble
et nos personnages étaient
ensemble, c'est la pire chose qui me soit jamais arrivée
le passé n'est jamais difficile, ne le sois pas
exagéré mais bon
c'était vraiment bien
tomber amoureux d'elle en faisant le
et la chose la plus difficile à faire le Duel c'est
quand un couple se sépare, ils prennent leurs distances
un peu il fallait se voir
toute la journée oui ou oui pour moi le meilleur
moments où nous avons enregistré dans
dehors Mais sérieusement avec le froid Oui
et aujourd'hui Miguel Ángel m'a rappelé un moment
qui, je pense, est mon préféré qui se trouve dans le
Plaza España la première saison
on tournait 18 heures par jour entre les répétitions
pas d'entretien le week-end
nous étions conscients du succès de la série
et du coup on a enregistré une chorégraphie en
le centre de Madrid et nous sommes arrivés et
accord que les gens ont commencé à nous faire
cercle pour nous demander des photos autographes vin
à la police et je me souviens que c'était le
la première fois que j'ai réalisé que
la série touchait les gens
reviens reviens
trois quatre
et aussi d'être ici en France, ce qui est
la porte de notre succès international
de la série La France a été le premier pays
qui nous a embrassé et bien la série est une des
la série la plus vendue en Espagne
nous sommes super heureux d'être arrivés
à l'aéroport, il y avait des fans dans l'hôtel
maintenant voilà, c'est ce que je fais
chose spéciale qui nous est arrivée il y a 20 ans
la vie nous a tous changé mais ça
Cela t'est arrivé deux fois dans ta vie parce que je
On dirait que c'est presque miraculeux et
voyez-nous maintenant comme l'ancienne génération
concernant la nouvelle génération et voir le
similitudes qu'ils vivent
ce que nous traversons c'est
très spécial nous sommes très heureux